If an app updates in the background,
but no one opens it to find out,
did it really happen?
Notification started off
as a convenient way to notify users
of background updates.
But they've grown to become
a powerful standardized shortcut
to interact directly with apps
in a lightweight way.
Starting in Jelly Bean
it was possible to expand notifications,
making them larger
and containing more information.
That also introduced the concept
of the rich notification,
which is able to include actions
like these, to be performed on the data
included within the notification.
This speeds up interaction
and helps users streamline
their notification triage experience.
As a standardized UI designed specifically
for conveying timely information
in limited screen space.
Notifications were the obvious mechanism
to use, when Android expanded
into wearables with Android Wear.
Suddenly those rich notifications
that you designed for phones and tablet's
make your app wearable
compatible, for free.
Don't overdo it though,
there's a fine line between
useful and spammy.
And it's only a couple of clicks
for a user to disable
your app's notifications permanently.
So check out the instruction
that's below for links
to the design guide
in creating good notifications.